the original film series is such a like
a touchstone for a generation
of people and it's so fun to see it come
back like the spirit seems the same
what do you remember about the original
series and like what about it carrie is
over in the new one
well what i remember about the original
series and
and movies in general at that time and
emilio estevez movies in general at that
time was like
kind of a a
a reality to them like a sort of
comedic but still we're gonna
show you people from different
backgrounds we're gonna
you know explore kind of what makes
friendships and
and when when i sat down with the
creators of this
iteration they talked about the classic
disney movies
you know like these big hearted um
beautifully done kind of you know warm
hopeful um stories and
all of that was appealing to me and i
and i do think the spirit of the series
because it's always
you know as i will know when you take on
or continue something that people really
loved and they have frozen
in their memory of you know it's a
challenge
and i just thought the spirit of the
the show was the same as as the movies
and and
of course you know to get to work with
emilio and have
his like stamp of approval to continue
it i think
hopefully will give fans what they want
what was it like
getting to work with him because you
know he's been doing his independent
films for a long time um and this is
like he as he explained to me he's like
mighty 3 was my out this is my back in
and it's so interesting that journey
what was it like being with him on set
it is interesting and it's and i also
he i didn't feel this way at all but
he talked about feeling rusty as an
actor and it
really is like a muscle that you kind of
you
you you get
better when you're using it and i didn't
see
anything but he's got such a natural
kind of um still
and smart quality to him and
i'm like more of a s
[Music]
not that so i really i really
thought we we had a nice chemistry from
the beginning
and and he's so smart it's it's great to
work with actors who are
conscious and aware of the entire
process
and and been the filmmaking of it all um
it enables you to i don't know just see
the whole picture
and and know what is needed
in a scene and and i just really enjoyed
talking to him i enjoyed talking about
politics and
um you know he's he's just a really
smart and interesting
interesting guy so i was glad to have
him as a partner
where does alex rank on your list of
like
cool strong moms that you've played
i cannot rank my moms but um
one thing that was different that i i
actually
um not struggled with but you know they
really wanted to tell the story of
of someone who is finding her feet is
finding her confidence
you know is not used to speaking up for
herself
and um and i'm used to
playing the person who has that
confidence already so
it was just an interesting um
i don't know an interesting layer to to
think about
where she is vulnerable that and i think
that
that made her a little bit um distinct
from from some of my other ladies
yeah you know the like right off the bat
i find super interesting just like the
concept of
what you're standing up for like what
this mom is standing up for
like i have two young kids too and the
idea to me is terrifying of that sort of
like
diving in head first your whole life is
about this thing that's going to cost
you
you know a mortgage and who knows what's
going to happen to your kid
like do you think like as a as a person
as an individual
do you think sometimes that people do go
a bit too far uh
over the edge with the sports and all
that stuff for sure
i have um uh a bunch of cousins who's
for some reason on one side of the
family it's like mainly boys
and a lot of uh those boys play hockey
and
one of my cousins saw a preview for the
show and she was like the moms are not
bad enough
you got to make them worse she was like
she was like it's
it's insane like you know and i i didn't
grow up with that
you know i i was a horseback rider but
no one was pushing me into it i
i i just i was ambitious my father in
fact was allergic to horses i picked
like the worst sport i possibly could
in terms of like you know having a
parent root me on so
like i love um dylan playfair who who
plays the
the coach of the of the scary team i
think he's hilarious
and just captures that like um
i don't know this captures the
ridiculousness
of of how much pressure
certain kids are under you know it's
just
it can't be healthy yeah finally you you
mentioned um
zoe's extraordinary playlist would you
return to that like did we
are we gonna see it going back i was
supposed to and
and that was part of um the fun of
getting to come back to vancouver was
both shows are there
and um and i love that character and i
love that show
and then it was coveted and i
i ended up having to quarantine a second
time because someone close to me tested
positive so that there went all the days
that we planned to to um to have some
you know uh room to to do joan but i
i mean i would love to go back i love
that show i love my friend jane
and i think it really continues to
to be such a creative show so yeah that
was my dream scenario
you